Speaker 1: Let's go to our friend
who have not heard from for so long.
Eric from Cancun. Eric, welcome.
Speaker 3: Much like it was so.
Speaker 1: Much of the UN Blazer Commissioner.
Speaker 3: And I tell you, why don't
martial arts and I try to apply for politics?
Speaker 1: You applied for politics.
What does that mean?
Speaker 3: And let me explain.
First of all, I do martial arts because it's a
sport and I want to give my muscles very strong
and very agile when they do the case
and also the influence. Also, because
I need it to protect myself when it's dangerous.
Speaker 1: Nothing wrong with that.
Speaker 3: And also that my simple tells
me that you need that balance between
it's a way to learn how to beat
violence without being aggressive.
My teacher tells me that we have to control our
impulses and that it would be a healthy way to
to go against those impulses that we have between
us and a monster that you need to control. Because
if you restrain yourself too much, then you
become very weak and cowardly. But if you don't
restrain that old, you become a jerk.
Speaker 1: So if I understand, Erik,
what you're suggesting is martial arts is a
good outlet to know when and to what degree
to use violence, but to be able to control
it when it should be controlled. Is that
right?
Speaker 3: Yes. And
because we are separate, we have our inner demons,
but also our inner angels. And we will be to know
when to let play the normal way to restrain them.
Speaker 1: Well, I think you're making some very
good points. This is what you said. This
is wisdom from your martial arts teacher.
Speaker 3: But also within myself,
making sure that he's fully since
he's not going to find anyone who wants
to use violence to do whatever they want.
Speaker 1: I like that. I like that. Listen, Eric,
how is Cancun these days? Is the is the tourism
industry flourishing currently in Cancun.
Speaker 3: Isn't it? I'm to mention
my Airbnb and here is going to be the by the
politics and martial arts. Okay. This is showing
like local reggae, which has the original cast
of characters again. Yes. And June in the Forest
by Johnny Lawrence. He's the Orient, the guy who
will pull us against the Americans, against Daniel
LaRusso. Do I get kicked in the face? You want
to reopen Cobra Kai? Because he has three rules.
Strike first and strike are no mercy. Right. But
also family. But you just context start first.
Needs to seize the moment. Like when you want
to grab the last bus of the instrument store
strike heart of yours to give your
best and for no mercy is to not
give up when you have the chance to win.
Speaker 1: All right, Eric from Cancun,
you have set it all. Thank you so much
for the call, my friend and buddy.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 1:
Okay. Thank you very much. There's Eric.
I know Eric always has more material,
but at some point we have to say that is it.